con todas las premisas de la última
serie de vídeos sólo queríamos tratar de
obtener o de descubrir cuando alguna
transformación de una transformación t
que va de nuestro espacio rn a rm cuando
esta transformación t es invertible
entonces realmente la pregunta que nos
hemos estado planteando es cuando te o
si estate en particular es invertible
invertible y para eso hemos de hecho
demostramos ya hace muchos vídeos que
una transformación que esencialmente es
una función verdad que que una función
para ser invertirle necesita dos
condiciones entonces si tenemos que es
invertible se necesitan dos condiciones
la primera de ellas es que la
transformación sea sobre y eso significa
que para cualquier punto en mi dominio o
en mi contra dominio verdad
necesitamos encontrar siempre a alguien
en el dominio que mapea al punto que me
había elegido verdad eso para cualquier
elemento de mick o dominio y por otro
lado también necesitamos que la función
o la transformación fuera uno a uno y
eso quiere decir que no puede haber más
de un punto que vaya a dar a otro en el
co dominio es decir si yo me tomo un
punto en el condominio solo puedo
encontrar a lo más uno en el dominio que
es mapeado a ese punto que me había
elegido
es manteado por a lo más uno del dominio
entonces si nos tomamos ahora el caso
particular de que esta transformación va
de rn a rm entonces esta transformación
te que
es aplicada un vector x de hecho sabemos
que lo podemos ver como la
multiplicación de una matriz de m por n
aplicado al vector x verdad entonces
para que esta transformación sea sobre
necesitamos que el rango el rango de
nuestra matriz a sea igual a la
dimensión de mikko dominio es decir que
sea igual a en esta misma m que esto es
lo que necesitamos y para que esta
transformación sea 1 a 1 ya también
demostramos que el rango de nuestra
matriz necesita ser igual a n esto es
para que sea 1 a 1 entonces ahora
pensemos que queremos que la
transformación sea invertible y si
queremos que la transformación sea
invertible se deben cumplir estos dados
es decir vamos a tener que combinar
estas dos características para que sea
para para ser invertible o cuando es
invertible se debe cumplir estas dos
condiciones
entonces realmente si queremos que sea
invertible el rango el rango de nuestra
matriz a debe ser igual a m que también
debe ser igual a n esto me está diciendo
que la dimensión del dominio y del
condominio en principio debe ser el
mismo ok entonces estamos pensando que
nuestra matriz a es una matriz es una
matriz cuadrada
es una matriz cuadrada y quienes estamos
pensando en la matriz
y es cuadrada y digamos que es de tamaño
n por n muy bien entonces vamos a ir
explorando un poquito más de esto si
tenemos nuestra matriz a y tenemos
digamos sus sus vectores columna a uno
digamos el segundo vector es a 2 y así
hasta el vector a n esta es nuestra
matriz a y expresado de esta forma y
como como la matriz o más bien la
transformación es invertible todos estos
vectores estos n vectores son
linealmente independientes y de hecho
como el dominio tiene dimensiones pues
pues en realidad estos forman una base
de nuestro espacio ok que de hecho es el
mismo porque dijimos que las dimensiones
deben ser iguales entonces qué es lo que
pasa con esto cuando llevamos a la forma
reducida y escalonada de esta matriz ok
digamos la la forma reducida y
escalonada pues esencialmente lo que
necesitamos es ver qué pasa con los
vectores pívot de verdad
y aquí tendremos que como todos estos
son linealmente independientes de que de
hecho forman una base cada uno de éstos
corresponde a un vector pivote entonces
aquí estará este vector pivote 1 0 y
puro ceros el segundo vector pivote que
es el 0 1 y puro ceros y así
sucesivamente esta matriz es de n por n
debería corregir esto aquí quería decir
n entonces todos los elementos de una
base que son estos se asocian con
columnas pivote entonces qué es lo que
podemos decir de nuestra forma reducida
y escalonada por renglones de esta
matriz a que de hecho esta es la matriz
la matriz de n por n en este caso que
dijimos que las dimensiones son las
mismas donde donde toda columna toda
columna es
una columna pivote es una columna
una columna
columna pivote pero además no cualquier
columna pivote sino que entre ellos son
linealmente independientes ok entonces
son linealmente independientes y cuál es
la forma de esto pues necesitamos
digamos el primer la primera columna
pues es el que tiene 10 y pudo ser es
verdad la siguiente columna es la que
tiene 0 1 y puro 0 es verdad de hecho
vamos a tener puros unos en la diagonal
y 0 en todos lados
muy bien entonces realmente estamos
pensando que esta forma reducida y
escalonada por renglones de la matriz a
no tiene que ser otro más que la matriz
identidad de n por n y ya tenemos una
condición muy agradable para que la
transformación sea invertible entonces
de hecho podemos ir resumiendo todo esto
que si tenemos una transformación que va
de rn en rn verdad entonces si la
transformación aplicada al vector x se
puede definir por una matriz a que de
hecho es es de n por n verdad si es si
está definida por la multiplicación de
una matriz por el vector entonces sólo
será invertible
sólo es invertible sólo es invertible
la forma reducida y escalonada por
renglones de nuestra matriz a es la
matriz identidad de tamaño n por n y de
hecho en el enunciado lo podríamos decir
de rn a rm verdad entonces aquí esta
sería de m por m y al decir que la
matriz identidad es de n por n el que es
la matriz identidad pues eso obliga a
que tienen que ser iguales pero bueno la
forma de que sea invertible es si su
forma reducida y escalonada por
renglones de la matriz de la
transformación es igual a la matriz
identidad de n por ena y ese es un gran
gran resultado para llevarnos ahora
usaremos eso en el futuro para resolver
algunos detalles de las inversas de las
transformaciones